self-awareness for writers you know we
always hear that great writers we talked
to uh
lee jessup and she said that
self-awareness is so important because
they need to know where they're lacking
and where they're strung but
how do we know who to ask and
where do we become more self-aware as a
writer
i think one of the ways you can become
more self-aware as a writer is to belong
to a writer's group
because i think the support that you get
from people who are going through some
of the same
challenges that you're going through
is inspiring to to one you become a
sounding board for one another and they
did a study at harvard or yale or one of
those ivy league colleges and they said
the people the writers who were in a
writer's group
seem to achieve success a lot faster
being in a writer's group than when
people writers would do it alone
so i do think that
that's a good way of becoming having
achieving more of for self-awareness and
to be more confident about who you are
and what your work is about
another thing you might want to try
doing is is actually
consulting with people like like lee
jessup or
if there's anyone else that you that in
particular that you've
come carol kirschner is another good
really good one
these two people in general really focus
on uh helping to get your career started
and i think that once you take those
first few steps with them
things become so much easier
so you know i i do
similar things but most of mine uh
really focuses on the business more of
the business end of screenwriting the
pitching the networking and and that
type of stuff so you know i do think
that there are people out there that can
help you with it lee is one person and
and carol kirschner is amazing too
you